[Music]
all right we are live on the YouTube
sorry about the delay there people the
amount of things that go into pulling
off one of these shows is well we could
probably do a show on that at some other
time I am live with the one and only
Colin Moriarty thank you thank you for
being here
thank you for having me yeah I was
thanking you for being here that's
usually the way it goes I interviewed
you last time so I guess I'm actually in
the same exact setup so yeah no it's
good to be here I I'm trying to say no
far less than people asking me to do
shows and I always say yes to you so
you've actually got me back into the
motion about doing like a few things in
the next few weeks oh it's awesome to be
here thank you so much yeah and
congratulations by the way on your
continued success oh well
congratulations on your continued
success as well well it's funny the way
that you just did that because you did
interview me in these two chairs for
your podcast which I hope most of my
audience's listen to and for those that
haven't I think they should if they want
to just get a different more insight or
take on what's going on in my mind and
some of my history I actually think it
was probably the best interview I've
ever done which is total credit to you
oh I think you got me to open up about
things that I don't talk about that much
and periods of my life that I that are
long gone and and all that stuff so oh
you're very welcome
you have hosted in that chair yeah but
I've hosted in that chair which is weird
too I interviewed my dad in that chair
this way so it's all it's being here's a
little confusing so thank you for being
you thanks for having me all right
there's a ton I want to do you know I
always say at the end of a good
interview that if I didn't look at my
notes once that's a good one every now
and again I have to look because I need
to know something chronologically or a
specific number or something
I'm not even bringing notes to the table
today because you've been doing this for
a while we met about a year and a half
ago you were just some guy with some
gaming site yep and you tweeted
something now actually I'm telling this
story slightly backwards because I had
had you on our show first when I thought
you were just the gamer again right I
just thought you were some video game
guy we were doing a YouTube week thing I
saw your handle on Twitter no taxation I
was like this guy's kind of kind of
interesting he looks like a hipster but
he seems to be a conservative I don't
know what to make of this and I had you
on and we do this
about an hour I thought we were gonna
talk about Super Mario Brothers the
whole time and you go into just an hour
of extremely well thought out cogent
politics and and your beliefs and I was
really impressed and I said to you I
think I said it on air I was like you're
gonna be a star in the world of politics
and thank you yeah and immediately you
were on with Glenn Beck and a whole
bunch of other stuff but something else
put you on the map and I know most of
the people know it but let's just recap
it for three minutes go sure on
International Women's Day which was just
passed again and I stayed off a Twitter
that day because everyone was asking you
know I I didn't want to insult anyone
else again but I tweeted out just a joke
about my girlfriend
peace and quiet peace and quiet hashtag
a day without a woman yeah and it was a
joke for you know my girlfriend who's in
ER nurse she had just gotten back from
an overnight shift so she was getting
into bed I showed it to her like an you
think this is funny yeah just like yeah
that's funny and then with the bed and I
got up took us you know tweeted it got
up went to work and then all hell broke
loose and obviously it was a with the
years hindsight with like some time to
think about it now I mean it was clearly
a political hit and I understand that
and you know I'm sorry if it hurt people
but that wasn't the intention obviously
and are you really sorry no not really
no I mean I know I know you you're a
good guy you like to apologize for
things like you don't want to hurt
people and all that but but really like
you said a joke yeah you're in bed with
your girlfriend yeah not auntie woman
you know no not that day anyway
yeah but the no I'm not sorry for the
people that got faux offended by it but
if there was some person in Lincoln
Nebraska that really was mortified and
had to stay in bed for a few days I
really do apologize about that but
anyway my whole kind of world blew up at
that point
I quit the company I found it and
started a week later my new company CLS
Colin's last stand and it's just been a
whirlwind of the year I mean it's just
been a wild year of learning and
figuring things out and failing and
succeeding and trying and it's been you
know 60 70 80 hour weeks I haven't had a
day off all year yeah I was reflecting
on that a few days ago to my girlfriend
even when we go to Vegas pretty often
and even when we were there last time I
was just working in the hotel room the
entire time I was there so I believed it
because for the amount of times that we
try to get together and I'm like I could
bump free for the taps our clear and
you're like I got 15 minutes this way
and bah-bah-bah but I thought it was I
wanted to
start with that story because I think
it's so relevant so much that has
happened since then in our first
interview when you did that YouTube make
sure you basically predicted that this
type of thing was gonna happen to you
one day that you would step in something
politically and that then it would all
blow up and all that and I think there's
a link to everything that's going on
right now with with this Kanye stuff
which we're gonna talk about and a bunch
more but it's so it's been up basically
a nutty year for you but you survived
and I think it's important to really
acknowledge that because even something
like the International Business Times
they wrote a piece about you in the
midst of all this where they talked
about your racist tweet right very can
you repeat the tweet again it was a
peace and quiet hashtag a day without a
woman so no no no hint of racism there
and you're the one to help me get in
touch with them and it but it was up
there for a day and you know the damage
was done yeah it's it's all just
transparent clickbait and this kind of
desire to destroy and you know I've been
trying to take a step back from that
precipice myself in the way I treat
others and have really been cognizant
about that the entire year that I've
been doing CLS because I don't want to
contribute to that I want tribute to the
reason into the knowledge and to the to
kind of the step-by-step process by the
way you and I reach our conclusions as
opposed to insulting and kind of getting
into the muck I don't I'm not super into
that so yeah but we all kind of get
sucked in every day that's right like
the best of us do it I try so hard not
to and then somebody does something so
ridiculous it's usually an author or a
journalist that writes one of these
crazy things about someone I know
calling you racist you know calling
Jordan Peterson this or Shapiro this or
Sam Harris that and I'm like I know
these people these are my friends you
you don't do research you don't do any
of the things that a journalist is
supposed to do but this just seems to be
proliferating throughout everything
right now it is but I think the Kanye
situation in just other situations kind
of parallel to it that are obviously
much smaller it's a sign that people are
not or there's large swaths of people
that are not necessarily buying into it
I think the major thing that the far
left in the United States is making a
mistake with right now is assuming that
because someone like me I don't like
Donald Trump I mean I'm very vocal at
that I don't like him I don't think you
should be President
I'm a conservative I don't think he's a
real conservative and that just because
I don't like him I like them yeah
there's no way in hell you know and
there's a huge swath of us that want
nothing to do with them
yeah and but also we're a little
uncomfortable with the way conservatism
is gone or the way you know kind of I'm
not really into a socially conservative
things and stuff like that like there's
a new way forward multiple ways forward
and so that's their big mistake so they
in sultanate and they and they slander
everyone but they're not really getting
new inherence by doing it they're
actually just isolating themselves and
isolating other people from them yeah
and so that's actually kind of good for
us and along in the long term and the
midterms it's gonna pay off for the for
the Democrats and the left but I don't
think long term it's gonna be a winning
strategy you know it's funny I know
we've talked about it a little bit I'm
not so sure that conventional thinking
on this midterm thing is right because I
think the left has gone so bananas the
media has gone so crazy the left hasn't
come up with one new idea they've just
doubled down on identity politics in
from every level from Bernie on down
it's just double down double down but I
don't know that there's anyone out there
who voted for Trump or even if you were
an independent that voted for a Gary
Johnson or whatever else that anyone
that didn't yeah but I don't know that
anyone that did that is gonna go you
know what in the year-and-a-half
putting you know if you can get over
tweets Trump tweets and stuff like that
I don't see how you could possibly be
like I'm gonna vote I'm gonna suddenly
vote for identity politics I'm suddenly
gonna vote for collectivism and leftism
what may happen is that they just won't
vote in which case the outcome that
you're predicting will happen but all
right I think because of some of the nra
stuff I think this Kanye thing the
general attack on free speech and
hysteria I think even actually may go
the other way I honestly haven't heard
anyone else say that but there's
contrarian Dave I guess no I mean geez
man I mean you were I don't think you
were we've talked about this in the past
but I don't think you were one of the
people that predicted that Trump was
necessarily gonna win but you predicted
that it was much more possible I think
you were on Rogen that day yeah I guess
yeah you know I think even it was the
more Nate Silver kind of school thought
of being like he has a third of it she
like won one in three times he'll win
which is much more than the 2% or
something on Huffington Post gave yeah I
don't know if midterms are always bad
for the incumbent party and it's always
for the most engaged part
so it's all gonna be about the real
Republicans in the real Democrats I have
no investment in it especially in
California I really could care less
about what's happening I would say but
as a California guy and we watch this
state kind of plummet into the depths of
hell I mean you were from you lived in
San Francisco when we first met just
about a year and years oh yeah for ten
years excuse me I know it's hard I just
wet saying San Francisco I mean you know
what happened I just went I spoke at
Berkeley a week and a half ago I had
dinner in San Francisco in the in a
seemingly nice area there were tent
cities that we were driving by on major
streets there were homeless people
everywhere I saw someone actually
ejecting something on like a corner side
thing I believe literally our car got
broken into while we were outside of a
nice restaurant right in front of a
Chase Bank broken into stole stole all
my stuff yes I mean they're not gonna do
anything I mean obviously they're not
even you know even filing a police
report well the guy wasn't my car it was
the couple who sponsored the events car
so they did file a report but people
then on Twitter when I put the picture
up we're like how could you leave your
stuff in your car in San Francisco
everyone knows that I didn't even
realize that it was such an epidemic but
it's a massive epidemic and on top of
that there's this app that tells you
where humans are pooping on the streets
of San Francisco yes I mean I'm not
making this up [ __ ] up no no nice double
entendre thank you I know San Francisco
when I moved to there in 2007 I had
interned there in 2004 too but I lived
there full-time starting in 2007 there
was a charm to the city it was still
bohemian it was still it was post Comair
a pre-recession there was still
something special going on there and
obviously the wealth disparity there has
not you know and I'm not really one to
harp about that but that's obviously
destroyed the city there's 200,000 more
people living there than when I moved
there no real new infrastructure lots of
Byzantine laws where buildings can't be
higher than three or four storeys and
lots of neighborhoods but wait wait wait
Colin I'm a simple guy so you have to
explain this I thought progressive
politics which that's the home oh yeah
oh yeah I thought that was there a fixed
wealth disparity no no it's it's it's
totally that's why you know and it's
touching Oakland and Alameda and and
saying not so much San Jose I guess but
parts of the valley where it's just San
Francisco just kind of fell apart and
before my very eyes and it's very sad
there's a lot to love about that city
and it's just yeah
progressive politics have taken it over
but more than that it's just you know
the tech industry is kind of ruining
things you're seeing an in Venice
actually to where I'm in I live in Santa
Monica now and snapchats in Venice and
you see it's amazing you see literal
tags everywhere spray-paint tags have
just you know snapchat [ __ ] snapchat
snapchat go home and stuff like you're
seeing kind of small things like that
happen there so it's a complicated
situation but California overall I mean
I love the idea of splitting it into
multiple parts and stuff like that so
that you know there are more Republicans
in California than any other state well
there definitely is a nascent Republican
or conservative or libertarian movement
here you know I had John Kasich in here
just a couple weeks ago and that's yeah
he was thanks he was here too with
Schwarzenegger to meet with California
conservatives to kind of figure out how
do we how do we step back from the abyss
right now that this state is going into
and most likely I mean it's pretty sad I
love LA you know from the day I moved
here a little over five years ago I have
loved it here every day and I've been
successful here and I've met tons of
great people and it's like man Gavin
Newsom who was the the mayor of San
Francisco who is as left of left of left
of left he could be the governor here I
mean so he could get worse than it is
you know he'll make Jerry Brown look
look moderate or make them look you know
something else Jerry Brown's the worst
by the way just the heat-seeking missile
that any public office whoo-hoo because
whose governor and then like Attorney
General mayor of Oakland then governor
like it's just like any open office
there's gonna be like the local
librarian or something in San Francisco
yeah would you before California really
splitting yeah I mean people are
grumbling about it now yeah absolutely I
think California you know we're from the
East Coast states are a little smaller a
little quaint they're a little more
colonial in their size the states out
here California is too big I mean what
is it like 1/6 of the country's
population in one state there's a bunch
of voiceless people here and I don't
blame them for wanting I'm one of those
voiceless people we were just talking
about taxes before the amount of taxes
that I paid last years is astronomical
would any people throw up in their
mouths of their if they knew you know
and it was revealing the numbers that we
paid in taxes and it's not cry me a
river here but I can I can honestly tell
you that I paid in taxes because I just
wrote the check you know a week or two
ago more basically than I made in almost
any year of my life until the last two
years that I ever made ya know I think
that that's what we're dealing with
absolutely yeah it's terrible I mean
success comes you know my accountant was
trying to talk me down being like it's
just a matter of success like relax you
know and I'm like I appreciate that I
respect that but to be robbed by the
state in such a gratuitous way and I get
nothing in return for it literally
nothing I don't know like what their
what they're doing with that money it no
it's super sad and I was telling people
on Twitter that you know with the
uncertainty that comes with owning a
business especially in California you'll
again also 1.5 percent of gross receipts
you owe to the state no matter if you I
think you made a profit or not which is
fantastic I would love to hire an editor
I'd love to hire someone full-time when
I looked kind of funny one of my major
things when we hire two people that
still work there that I never got to
work with one of my major things was
like let's pay them well let's pay them
fairly and give them security and give
them something that they can rely upon
and I'd like to do that for an employee
of mine as well but now they have their
hands in my pockets and I just don't
know yeah I don't wanna bring someone on
for six months promise them the world
and then be like it's not working out
yeah and a lot of that comes from
financial and you know the kind of
financial uncertainty with living in
California I was making life I have no
idea why I'm really here you know I go
live in Alaska or something I do the
same exact thing I'm doing you know so
yeah I thought it was just so that every
now and again we could play contra
together well I love and you're right
about the mist like that the our Mis
schedules I often when I'm around where
you live I often text you like on the
fiving I'm going to a meeting here are
you available yeah from 1:00 to 2:00 it
never works out so you're one of the
reasons I'm here usually like I'm in the
Dagobah system and I can't make it there
right now all right well look I I have
no intentions with you right now other
than let's just shoot the [ __ ] I want
you to question me as much as I question
you but I do want to dive into the Kanye
thing a look at it cuz I think and I'm
doing my direct message tomorrow about
this I think there has been an awakening
I mean I think this thing is absolutely
huge that being said I don't know what
tremendous him but I don't I'm not a
huge fan of Kanye beyond the headlines I
don't know that much about him but I
know that this guy is a mover this guy
is someone who truly by what he says can
change culture I do know Candace
personally and I've had her on a bunch
and we were just at Berkeley last week
and I'll be in New Hampshire with her on
Tuesday I like her a lot she's evolving
as she's doing all this that puts her in
a very dangerous precarious position
right now to have so much of the
microscope on her hair this is all
evolving
do you think that him just tweeting
those seven words the seven dirtiest
word since George Carlin you know I
whatever was I love the way Candace
Owens ranks do you think I'm overstating
the importance of this maybe I I think
it's important because like you said
Kanye's like almost looked at within
many spheres like as almost like a
modern-day philosopher in a way
and I've always been mixed with him I'm
a huge hip-hop fan actually and I've
never really I don't like brash which is
funny because I'm pretty brash but I
don't like brash arrogant people I just
that doesn't turn me on
especially with artists I like humble
people with with art people that are
like I know I'm good but I don't need to
tell you how good I am all the time and
he always kind of rubbed me the wrong
way in that sense but you can't deny
especially that record graduation what
from 2007 which I love you can't deny
the greatness of his music and so it's a
big deal to your point because he's
touching base with a group of people
that are totally unaligned with anything
that we're talking about probably
unaligned with any politics generally
they're going through their lives are
trying to survive they're going to
school they're raising a family whatever
and so I think you're right do you
really believe though that this is like
the this is like a high turning point
yeah I think we're at a transcendent
moment right now I think there are so
many there I think that there are
literally millions and millions of
people in this country and in the world
who have been waking up to all of the
things that we've been talking about
related to political correctness and
free speech and just the way that you're
treated if you think a little bit
differently then the mainstream wants
you to think and he just gave them air
he just said hey guys here's a little
cover and it's interesting because when
you see the people that support us look
we're both fan funded right on patreon
people yeah people like our content but
our content still going up for free so
people are paying us because they are
there's like a pride in us and like oh
you guys are saying something you guys
are actually they're not just doing it
so that I can sit down and have an
interview with any old schmuck or so
that you can make some irrelevant videos
right they actually believe that we're
taking some position that has value
otherwise they wouldn't pay for it
because there's a lot of other content
out there
and I think he just gave room for now a
lot of other people to say you know what
there's probably more than 20 people who
think like I do but they haven't had any
cover and I think I just gave them
covering and I know Candice and Candice
is gonna freaking grab this thing and
run with it and I just worry about what
the media is gonna do about I mean
yesterday Daily Beast BuzzFeed and
mediate a media I used to be good they
all ran pieces about how what a
far-right person Scott Adams is yeah
it's Scott Adams I've got his book here
I never heard him you know yes did he
did he basically like Trump although
when I had him on before the election he
wasn't even a trump supporter yeah he
basically like Trump that doesn't make
you far-right far-right has much more of
a feeling about like an ethnic version
of the United States or related to
immigration and all I've never heard him
me really talk about any of those things
I think a lot of that has to do you and
I have talked about this you hit the
nail on the head actually with something
you said to me I think it might have
been private actually where the the
moniker all right is so meaningless and
the so-called alright which exists a few
thousand people whatever it might be
have no systemic power right they have
no power and I think people have finally
started putting two and two together
that wellick waiting so a Dave Rubin for
instance with of what the all we're at
the all right makes no sense because
Dave Rubin actually has a voice of
platform and respectable people give him
credence so they've moved what do they
call the it the Overton Window there's a
weird window yeah they've moved it a
little bit too though actually to the
center just a little bit and now they're
trying the far right thing and they do
that to me too right I I don't
III don't know that I have really any
far-right ideals other than I you know
I'm a proud of the Unites States I
believe in borders and all those kinds
things but I'm Pro I'm pro-choice I'm
Pro gay marriage I'm probe drug
legalization Pro prostitution illegal
ization all those kinds of things yeah
very far-right positions and and they
often throw that stuff at me but it's
it's about it's about insulting people
and sticking them with things that they
can't shake no matter what's true and
what's not
yeah Kanye's above that which is really
awesome he doesn't give a flying [ __ ]
what anyone thinks he's never had he
never has and that's something you have
to respect about him so you might be
right
I just think that that's all people need
people need when I had Douglas Mari in
here and at the end I see you know who
talks about all sorts of very
politically incorrect things right I
mean his book is called the strange
death of Europe talking about
immigration I've actually been meaning
to read that yeah I'll lend it to you
right there please yeah
he at the end I said what gives you the
bravery to take these positions and you
know he said it in a British accent
so it sounds better than I'm gonna say
it right now but he said you know when
you get in the pool you realize the
water isn't that cold and I think that's
all people need we're not being
slaughtered out there yeah it sucks when
people write shitty things about you and
say lies about you and you can spend
your whole life trying to correct their
lies which actually just breeds more of
them because they know you'll Drive more
clicks right all that but the average
person out there just wants to be able
to say what they think and and really
what you just said which is you just
gave me a pretty mixed bag of political
views that you have right there I think
they're basically libertarian views
pretty much and we're pretty much
aligned at most of this stuff but that's
what most people are we have some
inconsistencies we have some things
we're not totally sure about but it
seems to me that's what they fear more
than anything else it's not like you
don't fear the real extreme this way or
the extreme this way you fear the real
people who were kind of like alright I
feel this way about taxes but maybe that
doesn't line up exactly how I feel about
guns those things shouldn't all be
congruent with each other exactly and I
also think that you know people that
kind of put themselves in these small
chambers and these small kind of very
very thin verticals where they have to
have everyone that agrees with
everything they say first of all these
people are hypocrites right these are
the same people that voted for Obama in
2008 when he was explicitly against gay
marriage so by their own a lodge yeah he
what have you voted for Obama in 2008 I
voted for Obama in 2008 if you voted for
him in 2008 you were against gay
marriage right this is I heard a bigoted
letter I forget that you must have been
a bigot right yeah exactly and it's so
the logic immediately falls apart it's
just incredibly stupid
flimsy logic put out by frankly stupid
people so if you if you just uneducated
people don't know anything about
politics pop political science or
history or anything like that and they
try to kind of pitch and hold people
instead of what I'd be more interested
in and what I'm trying to kind of get to
a point with and I think you're in the
similar boat is let's ignore the things
for once that we disagree on what do we
agree on right I think we're getting to
a really interesting point for instance
with marylin marijuana legalization in
the u.s. now with cory booker talking
about it and chuck schumer talking about
it this is a place where by the way you
as a conservative should be freaking
really pissed at the republicans and I
know you don't consider yourself a
Republican per se but when Chuck Schumer
is out there a couple days ago talking
about states rights related to Merrill
and that and that that these idiot
Republicans let the Democrats they let
dorky Chuck Schumer get ahead of them on
weed and states rights which Rand Paul
should have been screaming about it's
like you're all messed up I mean that's
the thing you're all frauds in your own
way and if you replace the thing if the
Republicans would just stick to some
basic conservative libertarian
principles man you got you got almost
everyone with half a brain no it's it's
it's insane because I agree with you and
I think that this conversation is hard
for some room I was a Republican until
Trump won the nomination I left the
party in protest so I want to be clear
that I oh I still I would like to go
back to the Republican Party and make it
into what I really want it to be which
is a party that says like we have to be
consistent we have to be consistent with
our views we want our guns because of
the Second Amendment we want our Fourth
Amendment rights 'as to you know illegal
searches and seizures and all those
kinds of things but those kinds of
individual rights also parlay to a
woman's right to choose they also go
towards a man or a woman's right to
marry another man or another woman these
are consistent sort of things or being
you know injecting yourself with
whatever you want doing whatever drug
you want these are consistent
conservative values I've been saying
that for years so let's let's pause on
one cuz the abortion one which I don't
know that we've ever talked about I'm
actually not totally sure on your full
feelings on this so let's let's just do
it sure so when you're saying that's
consistent with a conservative view yeah
usually what conservatives will say
about that so when I've had Prager in
here and Shapiro and a bunch of other
people and we've debated this stuff
because I am pro-choice I always say I'm
for grudgingly pro-choice up until
twenty twenty weeks I think it's a
horrific choice but okay what they would
say is the government is supposed to
protect life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and that life is the first one
right so how do you square that away
with conservative beliefs well life
liberty and pursuit of happiness is not
a legal doctrine first of all so that's
that's one thing I would say second of
all the spirit of it is right but you
have to this is where this is where
tough conversations and like kind of
compromise come into play you have a
situation I always use a situation the
sixteen-year-old girl gets pregnant
right you're just gonna she's just done
that's it she's just she has no choice
no choice in the matter she has to carry
this baby to turn maybe she's six weeks
in she has no options to get rid of the
baby if she wants to this is gonna ruin
her life she's probably drop out of high
school she's gonna be on the system
she's gonna be working
no skilled jobs on food stamps all these
kinds of things it's ridiculous I
understand and I were worse by the way
because as Michael Shermer talks about
the rates of infanticide in places that
you can't have an abortion go way up
exactly so I respect actually the states
rights issue where if at Alabama or
Texas want to make it hard to have an
abortion fine like just go to another
state I know that that's not ideal but
that is the laboratory of the republic
working but so would you be for a
reversing roe v wade then it would
depend on i would only be down for
reversing it it i actually think your 20
week thing is actually extreme i'm not
even i think like 12 or 14 weeks at the
most but you have to give people a way
out because it's not as simple as saying
well that's a life well so is the person
carrying it and it's just not it's more
complicated than that
it was way more complicated than than
narrowing it down to this to this black
and white thing it's very gray it's not
binary and so i don't think a woman
should be walking in at 5 months unless
she's in serious trouble having an
abortion
and i don't think you can tell the
sixteen-year-old girl that her shitty
boyfriend's condom broker they don't you
know i was 16 once
even if they [ __ ] up even exactly i've
got to give them a way out and i know
it's i always call it you you said that
your begrudging about it i always called
a 60-40 issue I was actually pro-life
until through college but if someone
actually at that time convinced me that
I was wrong that's just you have to give
women a way out and I understand that
this is a tough this is a tough world
dude it's the same thing with you know
immigration yeah ideally we'd let
everyone into the country enjoy the
American life you know have a family
here but it's impossible you have to you
have to live in the real world so what
do you what do we do then in a situation
where okay you've made some pretty sound
arguments and I'd be happy to have you
back here with one of those guys who
takes the counter on it and we can
definitely do that but if you take it
it's not about them in this case I think
it's about the set of people that will
say if you show any nuance now you must
hate women or you hate babies or if you
or you take a nuanced immigration stance
you're a racist or and it's like we've
give we've seeded so much power to this
set of people that it make that then you
get people screaming build the wall
build the wall and it's like oh I guess
that kind of makes sense a lot of people
just concede you know it Amin if I'm
stuck between open borders and build the
wall
a sensible person probably is gonna say
build the wall you know that's not that
should not be their default position as
a thinking human being but don't you
think that reactionary politics in that
way makes sense sometimes like when
because it's what you're saying it's at
the rubberband affected and just in
videogames things rubberband and snap
back quickly if you're not reasonable I
think that the rubberband becomes much
more taut if you're not having these
tough conversations so it's okay to
either be undecided or to have kind of a
nuanced view on things which I have a
new one so if you want almost everything
I think most people do you know but it's
funny you say that because you know
there are certain things people try to
peg me like oh I'm some people have
accused me of being transphobic because
I once told a transgender person that
they're free to live their lives to
their exact specifications with no
infringement from the government even if
you want to live as a made-up gender
that was how it does how I figured out
well they are made of genders it doesn't
mean that you can't live that way I
don't care but to act like these things
are you know organic parts of human
history or it's not true right so I have
no I have no problem with you doing
whatever you want calling yourself
whatever you want and I will respect you
and call you that you have been to
dinner at my house with Blair white yes
I we had a great rug
yep did she smoke weed no no she barely
drinks it yeah I don't think she smoked
I certainly smoked though you definitely
smoke we yeah a trans person yeah I told
through the transports it was amazing
but the point I'm trying to make is like
that's the quote yes that's a clip right
there it's perfectly fine with me too
for you to live your life tears if you
want to if you're a man and you want to
be a genderqueer you're a woman and you
want to be a zoo or whatever that's cool
I have no problem that I'm not gonna
judge you I'm not gonna disrespect you
but me saying something like oh this is
kind of a manufactured thing of more
recent times for you to find your
identity in a way that makes you happy
that's transphobic so and I'm like but
I'm an ally of your of your community
you know that sense that goes to the
hysteria though because I I agree with
your basic principle there which is live
and let live do whatever the hell you
want but you can't do it on my property
you can't steal my [ __ ] you can't kill
me okay fine we're good but you know
leftism or that thing whatever that is
progressivism whatever you want to call
it it wants more than live-and-let-live
it wants
live and also apologize to me or bow to
me forever and that's the part that I
think people now and that's the part
that I think Kanye was
fed up with sure he was waiting I think
for a Candace to show up he was just
waiting for someone to stare black lives
matter down and say don't be a victim be
a victor like this same stuff of just
it's your life you kid grab it run its
show it's short right the light life is
short this window we have is very short
it's it's they the far-left believed in
live in obey and that to me is and it
really just obey yeah and you can't it's
the same thing to happen to me I was
called a racist because I said Asian
Americans on every metric do better than
white people in the United States
they're for white supremacy can't be
this overarching theme in every corner
of the country right that was really a
celebration of what Asian Americans have
managed to do with all sorts of the
Chinese Exclusion Act and gen and
Japanese internment Asians starting in
the post of war in the Reconstruction
era especially Chinese people that came
to the west coast never had it easy
they managed to figure things out we
should celebrate that we should look at
it and say what have they done that we
can including white people who were
doing worse yeah what can we learn from
that
is it the family system you know
multiple families are living in the same
dwelling is it an emphasis on education
what is what could it be that was racist
so isn't that the most perverse part of
this the hatred of success ridiculously
the hatred of success because when we
look at Asian Americans who by and large
because of education I mean we know it's
not rocket science it's because of
education this is the same thing with
Jews they don't like minorities who
succeed which is why a couple weeks ago
I know you're a Simpsons guy too
there was the whole I'm not by the way
well no no but but I don't I don't want
it people don't even in the peak years
know what we can get into the whole
thing with that but ya know it's it's
wait give me give me a minute on that
whoa so week years you're talking in the
mid-90s wait yeah no so my my best
friend Mike and a few people around me
Brian all these guys that I grew up with
all love the Simpsons and I would watch
it with them and then Washington
syndication right I actually had the
similar experience with DBZ Dragonball
to an extent I never got it it was just
one of those things from like I think
you know there are much funnier cartoons
in the Simpsons but but that's just I'm
sorry I don't mean the disappointment
teachers I really thought we got there I
thought we got where we had to be
Wow to each his own is right all right
well but you did see the controversy
over the problem without Poole that
ridiculous I love the way they handled
it I mean what are you saying Indians in
America from India by and large have
done everything right our doctors our
lawyers are socioeconomically successful
highly educated they've done everything
does that mean that no bigotry exists
does that not mean that maybe somebody
was called up who and the school yard
and bob up of course not this is not a
perfect system we've all had bad [ __ ]
happen to us but but this need that I
saw from some people to then grab it and
be like were the victims and it's
because of this cartoon despite all of
the facts and also the fact that the
character Appu is a beloved character on
what I would say is the greatest comedy
of all time the longest-running comedy
in the history of the elevational even
more than yeah I would say the breadth
of the work probably shorter but but
that Appu in the show they one of the
biggest episodes is about you know the
most influential episodes is about him
not being kick Homer at first ones him
kicked out of Springfield they do
immigration because him they do indian
weddings and indian culture he hangs out
with homer and goes to the bike it's
like this is america you [ __ ]
no absolutely by the way the Indian
wedding I went to an Indian wedding for
the first time a few years ago
exhausting
holy God just absolutely exhausted a
really they're really into it yeah two
days it's awesome we can we get married
in boring ways the point is is that
because the identity' know that
identities so it's so alluring to be the
victim yeah that's that it's the victim
mentality and you know there even I know
it's hard to believe but even white male
straight white males you're not a
straight white male about I'm a straight
white male can be victimized anyone on
TV you do you do know I always loved who
was it that was us it was at Skye
Williams that was on that didn't know
yeah I love that epiphany then yes Guy
Williams gay black guy now booted from
Twitter fortunately I mean what I'm sure
I'm next I'll give it you know yeah I
don't know that I say anything that
offensive but the point is to me Dave is
that it's good to have complicated and
uncomfortable situations that put you
sometimes are uncomfortable situations
because it's just being real I know
what's in my heart I know that I don't
believe in any of
things that and and aren't the things
that the worst things that people call
me right it's not gonna stop me from
grabbing the third rail sometimes and
saying what I need to say so having
complicated conversations about race
where you say like well you know
Nigerian Americans are actually the best
educated per capita Asian Americans from
you know whether from Vietnam whether
from Laos or whether from China or
whether from Japan are doing pretty well
the United Sates it doesn't mean that
they don't experience racism it doesn't
mean that some of them are poor of
course that's true but it means that I
I'm super interested in like what what's
happened what can we all learn from it
can we can we the high tide raise all
boats
what if we're so focused on identity
then why don't we focus on the positive
things that are happening to some of
these identities as opposed to only the
negative things and learn and grow
together in this kind of beautiful
melting pot that we are supposed to
celebrate and not it's almost like a
it's almost like a new form of
segregation in a way where poor people
almost like you know white people can't
enjoy this or black people can't say
this or Hispanics can't say this or I'm
like can't we all just ignore all of
these things that have actually held us
back for so long and to live a 21st
century life yeah where these things
aren't that important and we've done it
better than any place on earth we have
taken many more people for more walks of
life who came here with last year
huddled masses yearning to be free and
all of us virtually everyone in America
almost everyone in America that's an
immigrant story has it better than the
person who came here well you know that
this is one thing where I think Trump is
just completely wrong where he keeps
saying they're not giving us their best
that's not what it says on the Statue of
literally right I'm not again and I'm
not saying you could just let everyone
in and I don't want drug dealers and
criminals in but this idea that they're
not giving it yes some sometimes you're
gonna get some great doctors and
physicists from Eastern Europe or
something but also we need to let in
people that want to make a better life
for themselves when I see y'all you know
we live in LA here there's a lot of
Mexicans here and they bust their ass
show me a group of people if I can use a
collective phrase here who work harder
in the freaking hot la Sun all day long
doing all these jobs that other people
don't want for less it's an incredibly
racist thing that you do see I'm sorry
to have to say that to you honest live
Roger
giving people credit for working hard
yes but that's exactly that's house yeah
it's so silly and so it's so weird
identity politics
intersectionality and all these kinds of
things are destructive and I know that
people look at me as like well you're a
straight white man you don't understand
and I'm like no I do understand I I'm a
student of history I went to nu for
American history I understand the plight
of the black person for instace that
doesn't mean I necessarily experienced
it yeah but I understand where you're
coming from and I'm sympathetic to those
things but I think that by living and
that's why I think what Candis Owen said
I'm not you know the hugest fan of hers
specifically because of the way she
treated Blair white and I have to still
meet her and I'd like to shake her hand
and talk to her but I'll make that
happen
I love that yeah but you know she did
hit the nail on the head it's like the
why are we looking to be victims you
know
when whatever you know I know it's kind
of a left turn but when everything went
back you know went haywire for me last
year around this time I could have been
a victim I walked away from kind of
funny I sold my shares I'd have to do
anything for a long time but I don't
want to I immediately got back in yeah
because I have to work I have to leave
it all out in the field I want to know
that if I fail or something bad happens
that I it was because of me not because
I didn't try hard enough or do enough
and so I'd love to see people of all
types all political ideologies skin
colors genders you know I'd you know
sexual identities whatever realize that
what binds us is actually our humanity
and we can get a lot of things done if
we actually just work together and and
proceed as human beings as opposed to
these these isolated alienated groups of
people that can't have anything to do
with each other so do you think there's
anything that can be done that will
break that monster that will really like
slay bat thing because I think this kind
of a thing might start I think we've all
been chipping I think a lot of us you
know Jordan Peterson having the number
one book has been chipping at this what
a great guy by the way I love listen to
them for not I mean I'm going on tour
with a guy we got 26 stops in 31 cities
on my head's going to explode mostly are
any of them around here there's there
are of course the one that's the closest
to my house I can't go to because I got
something else but yeah there's a cup
there's long beach in June and Seattle
in Portland and what will get you to
somebody
yeah I'd like to go to what the ticket
is on me my friend oh I appreciate and
I'll see if I can get you to dinner with
Jordan how that would be awesome I look
what I'm trying oh my god thank you so
much but I think that being might crack
but it seems to me that it's still
getting worse yesterday was just another
example of something kind of happened
here look all kinda did forget tandace
for a second all kinda did was tweet a
couple videos about Scott Adams the fact
that they all felt the need to now call
him far right that shows you they can't
stop no matter how many times we mock
them for it no matter how many times
they get two retweets and we get a
thousand while mocking them or all of
those things not that Twitter is the
exact scientific way we can gauge any of
this but they never see the real
attraction and they're a dying monster
but they're gonna keep going down with
the ship and what I'm afraid of is
they're gonna bring down a lot of other
good [ __ ] with it right I agree well
it's a matter it's what you said before
and I'll check you with something that
you said to me in the past bring it
because I think it's really important
and you've said this to me and you're
right so keep it in mind is that just
the idea do these people really
represent as big of a group or a wider
swath of people as we think right our
Twitter's loud social media is loud it
communism seems big on Twitter but
communism is is is the most brain-dead
thing that's ever happened and there are
clearly not that many real communists in
the United States right but it seems
like it's like I'm a thing right and I
wonder if it's just the same people it's
the same thing in gaming industry right
with with far-left gaming industry
far-left games journalists they just are
all friends with each other and
perpetuate their own stuff but no one's
really reading anything they're writing
it like a dude with a webcam on youtubes
doing more traffic than all of Waypoint
or all polygons yeah right well Holly
God that was the one that you know I was
a little out of the gaming world and
then all this [ __ ] goes down with you
and then polygon was like writing things
about me that were not right and I was
and then of course you know you retweet
it and you show them and then they don't
respond but we're not journalists well
what's so weird is that they're they
want to write about you and I and some
more innocuous [ __ ] but one one of their
video producers is basically called out
as a sexual deviant maybe you don't see
many things that of them writing about
that yeah there's a little screen a
little strange is there a connection
since I'm out of the video game world a
little bit although I want to talk some
video games today because yeah I hijack
the last one I don't want to yeah but
you have dragged me back into the world
of games and I'm happy about that good
but is there a connection that maybe is
something through gamergate and
everything else about that when you're
playing games right and I you know I'm
sort of back in now and I'm what am i
playing and playing that tsun4 axiom by
my friend Tom hat yeah how cool I was I
called you up like I'm fine I finally
found a game I like you're like oh yeah
my buddy created and like yeah awesome
so I'm playing this game it's sort of
like an old-school Metroid yeah and you
have to do a lot of the things
repetitively to really figure it out I
had to FaceTime with you because I got
stuck in these two stupid walls and okay
whatever but that you have to accomplish
something in a video game you have to
keep trying to succeed yes can you go to
game facts or can you get the cheat code
and all that said you do but it really
is about you figuring out how to do all
this stuff and that to me sort of shows
why the media and especially the leftist
media hates games now or hates gamers
they don't like people who solve
problems and my is this a bridge too far
or am I on to something I don't know I
haven't really thought I have to think
about I've really thought about it I
think there's something there gamers you
want to get [ __ ] done whatever world
you're in whether you're playing a
sports game or an adventure game or an
RPG or whatever you're trying to you're
building something you're accomplishing
something you may have to have teammates
and it'll do it you don't want people to
help you do everything and cheap for you
that's not what the left likes sure no
they have to not like games I think
there's something really there well I
think gaming is becoming complicated
like that the world of gaming and I've
been a professional in it since 2002 so
it's been a long time I've been you know
immersed in this world and it's becoming
complicated and I'm concerned about it
because I'm concerned about it from
multiple reasons some of the reasons
people might not want to hear right one
of the things that you hear a lot now
because the left-wing domination
especially if games media makes it seem
like everything's through left-wing
prism is that people are saying now like
well games and politics don't belong in
the other games and I don't want
politics and games oh you're so [ __ ]
wrong when you say that games and
politics belong together in two million
it's a it's a work of art we should be
having political criticisms of them my
whole thing is like where is the
conservative criticism where's the
libertarian or moderate criticism I
tweeted out the other day Eurogamer
which is actually a website I like a
pretty serious video game website
tweeted out a piece by my friend cazza
is to work with that IGN she was a great
writer she is a great writer and she
said there's a diversity problem in
games and she was talking about how
there's not enough female writers and I
should tweeted out that's not the
diversity problem in video games there
are actually lots of female writers if
there could always be more but there are
plenty of them what the diversity
problem is is that you can't name one
conservative person on any of these game
website staff and after I left the IGN I
was an open conservative ever since then
you couldn't find one
so that's the diversity problem and that
blew up and got me in a lot of trouble
with games media who apparently is
scared of the diverse ideas because I
said higher Trump voter hiring
evangelical there's got to be a trump
voter out there who knows how to code
again well 55 million people you know
voted for Trump I would assume they play
video some of them play video games so I
hate that that's the takeaway that
people are getting because of the
political kind of nebulous nature of
games and how it's being written about I
think that that's destructive but it's
becoming more positive because games
that are becoming politically criticized
for things like a lack of diversity do
you know the game Kingdom Come
deliverance by chance have you ever
heard of that oh I'm not sure it's a
really nerdy open-world role-playing
game made by a Czech studio in Prague
and they made a game based very
historically accurate game on 13th
century Bohemia right and the criticisms
from Waypoint and polygon or where are
the people of color and these guys are
saying literally like we actually have
full-time historians working on this
game this game is now being taught in
Czech universities for how historically
accurate it is where are the people of
color in 13th century Bohemia that's the
that's your takeaway so it's this kind
of [ __ ] that's turning people off right
and I want people to engage and be like
no that kind of criticism I guess is
valid but we need some other kinds of
criticism which is what I'm trying to do
I once said I think on a live stream
just as like a sidebar or just like a
throw away I was like you know leftism I
think I said either leftism or
progressivism is a mental disorder
that's how Michael Savage oh is that
right he wrote a book called liberalism
as a mental all right so I don't so you
know my difference between leftism and
liberal is you're putting that aside for
a moment I was just sort of a throw away
that I said but when I hear you say
things like that like part of me it
rings like I'm not diagnosing anyone
with a mental disorder right now but if
you are living in a world where you are
trying to find something wrong with
everything else that has been created
instead of creating something that is
your own that does strike me as a type
of mental disorder like it's like a like
a cognitive dissonance I mean what you
can do with reality you don't do
anything with your reality so you
destroy someone else's reality
that's exactly right and that's that's
the I think this feathers back perfectly
what you were saying before about social
media and kind of the assassination
squads that go on over there over there
if you look at some of these people
certainly in games journalism there's
some great people doing game journalism
by the way some really really great
people Jason Schreyer is doing a bang-up
job there they're really smart good a
political people or people that feel a
certain way but don't inject it all the
time into that what they're saying so I
don't wanna make it seem like everyone's
bad that's and my old site IGN I think
is doing a great job too but if you read
some of these people's feeds there's
this guy named Ethan networks of Kotaku
who talk [ __ ] about me all the time and
I often wonder and I looked recently
because someone's like he's tweeting and
making fun of you and I looked and and
yeah you know several hundred maybe a
thousand favorites and you know about me
but then you scroll through his feet and
no one gives a [ __ ] what he says about
ya about his work how can you work for a
site like a taco and have two thousand
Twitter followers that's it for years by
the way that to me says that like you
just don't resonate with people and so
the only way you can get attention is by
dragging other people down and I've
realized this 2018 dave has been really
interesting for me because it's the
first time I've had time to think about
what's happened right like everything's
settling a little bit I'm working still
a lot but had time to reflect and I
realized that I can only control what I
can control
try to put a little bit more positive he
I'm always going to defend myself and
stuff like that but try to put a little
more positivity in the world and focus
on the fact how good people like you and
I have it that what I tweet out one of
my videos my videos do 50,000 views or
something crazy but they get you know
sometimes 500 retweets or a thousand
favorites right and these guys that are
hurling stones can't get that kind of
attention on their work without dragging
someone else down and I just don't want
to exist in that world anymore so so
that a guy like that can talk all the
[ __ ] he wants and be as negative as he
wants but he knows deep down that no one
cares about anything he says unless he's
trying to take a shot at someone and I
don't have that problem so it's and you
don't have that problem so maybe we can
be all more positive together yeah well
I think that that is maybe the next step
of all this which is where we'll all
just sort of redouble down because I
think we've doubled down already on this
it's clear we're not going anywhere
right I don't know and we can't go
anywhere okay
we have there two people relying on us
especially you you know that's why I'm
and I know I you know I know you don't
like when I compliment you too much on
the show but you're doing something
that's very important because you're the
proxy for these people right you have to
I told you that the first time I was on
the show before anything even happened
that you were the conduit by which a lot
you speak for a lot of us and I'm and
trust me dude you were talking about how
it hard it is for you to see people
talking about me or about Jordan or
about you know Joe who's now getting
dragged in all the [ __ ] - and who's the
greatest podcaster of all time as far as
I'm concerned it really just strikes me
the same way when I did see people
talking [ __ ] about you but I'm just like
you know what Dave's doing fine yeah and
I'll be there when he needs me but he's
doing the good work and the silent
majority supports him and you can see it
in the patreon support you can see it in
the viewership and all that kind of
stuff so we're touching lives and that's
important yeah and well it's all well
thanks and it's I guess at some level
there's something else interesting
happening here which I think Eric
Weinstein has mentioned on this show a
couple times I know he's mentioned it to
me privately that you need that in life
like what you just offered up there that
I know you've got my back you know I've
got your back
all these other people like it defending
yourself all the time is exhausting it's
exhausting and it's painful and it's
like that's why yesterday I don't even
know Scott Adams that well I've spent
about two and a half hours with him
every moment of it except for three
minutes on each side has been on air so
it's not like I've ever even had a drink
with the guy or broke bread with the guy
but I basically have a sense that he's a
good guy
I think he's an interesting thinker and
everything else but when I saw them
going after him this way the way that I
see them do it to everybody I was like
Scott can now either spend the rest of
his day defending himself which is no
fun or I can offer him a little bit of
cover and I was like I'm gonna offer him
a little bit of cover am I gonna get a
little bit of hate for it yeah I am but
I think it's I just think it's important
you know why why did that Hobbit work
with those other guys I still don't know
why I don't know why either that thing
was so long it was very like what was
like what do you people do I love
Tolkien I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna [ __ ] too much on that like
yeah yeah well no I agree with you it's
it's back beat having that cover there's
bored I told you that after what you did
for me that I'll have your back forever
right and I mean it if you ever were
broken down to the side
I have no rhyme no ID come get you right
like this I got a little roofing that
needs to be done after this you see what
I might be able to figure out a thing or
two for that you know I'm not most of
them very efficient with it you know
you're from Long Island you'll figure
yeah of course yeah
so that kind of covers important in as
long as we have each other's backs we
have to keep the powder dry though
that's the big thing that I feel like I
see too much of not so much from you or
our sphere but I see another more
politically active spheres they're
always fighting I'm gonna keep the
powder dry show a little bit of
restraint and then when we really do go
and try to save something I think it
resonates more that's the only thing I'm
trying to keep in mind these days it's
like these a little battle these little
fights I see something that [ __ ]
annoys me every day like that I want to
write how many tweets have I written and
just deleted before I even posted them
right yeah because when I pick out that
one in ten that really does get me you
know maybe people will pay more
attention to it I know I got to get
better at this too I really try but even
just an hour before we started this or
two hours ago
George Takei tweeted something so
something but I'd had him on my old
Sirius XM show like I'm sure he's a
perfectly fine person but he's just in
he's in progressive brain fog or
whatever you want to call it and he just
tweeted out something so stupid about
the way we at people would be treating
George Bush okay now Hollywood buddy
treating him okay but Trump is a bridge
too far now regardless of your feelings
on Trump it's like we know damn well how
they treated George W Bush so pretending
yeah so it's pretending and I'm not even
defending George W Bush it's irrelevant
but like just and I of course I then
went after him and it's like I was at
right after I was like you never feel
good about it right like it sometimes
it's necessary first of all George felt
that the way people treated george w
bush's the reason we got trump number
one you can draw a clear line and that
so maybe people should be a little more
cognizant of the words fascism not
seeing all those kinds of things in
according MIT Romney a sexist when you
have a real sexist in office right it
doesn't look so you know so that's
important that brings us back to like
that's why I love you people don't know
I thought you're talking about Bill
Clinton for a second you're talking
about Trump bill cranes the rapist
well maybe I'm not I mean America is the
monetization on this one I'm so sorry
yeah but isn't it interesting to about
like the whole thing with with was a
wanita Broderick and all yeah it's not
like she's not believed but we mocked
mocked literally by by Joy Behar on this
it's a little strange you know I don't
know if he's guilty or not but I always
just find that I always found that a
little weird and actually like Bill
Clinton is a politician so it's not even
that it's just like pretty nefarious
[ __ ]
but nonetheless I just think that we
need to be you know better to each other
there's these extremes on both sides
there are people on the far right that I
piss all the time my biggest some of my
biggest patron drops were when I made a
video about the about how the
Confederate flag is the flag of traitors
and all those kinds of things and those
people are easy to annoy to and their
identity politics are pretty much
equivalent by the way to the identity
Pollock's of politics on the left were
something that's that's not talked about
it too much so just cut those people off
yeah
80% 90% of the people in the middle I
think are gonna be receptive even if
they don't agree with you are gonna be
receptive to a normal line of thinking
about any policy policy prescription
that you might have all right so let's
do a little dive here or something and I
we we talked about this when when you
interviewed me so to this point that one
of the criticisms that I get is I'm too
easy on the right right I'm just too
easy on the right now what I've been
trying to explain to people is that as
someone that came from the left those
were the issues that I was really
focused on for a long time am i part of
the left anymore
obviously not I mean anyone in there
yeah I'm not obviously I am liberal and
that has nothing to do with that right
but I still do that as the biggest
societal problem that we have in America
I view those ideas as so toxic they
could truly topple this entire
incredible experiment are there terrible
people on the right that are true KKK
white nationalists really race realists
or whatever yes but as you said earlier
those people have no institutional power
I do not believe that Trump is one of
them they are not teaching at
universities they don't even have the
numbers but every time one of them does
something that everyone pretends it's
this massive thing so to for me to focus
on that thing that really has no power
that's already been overblown to me
seems crazy so are there issues that I
have with the with the the right as a
general thing I mean we could talk about
gay marriage and I'm pro-choice and a
poor uShip euthanasia and I'm for
legalizing marijuana for performing the
prison systems I'm for public education
though I would kick it back to the state
right these things should all anger
these people on the right yet I keep
getting invited all these places by
these crazy evil conservatives and
getting standing ovations when I talk to
turning-point you
say and all the libertarians love me so
it's like when I I can only view the
world as it is not as I magically want
it to be but do you think I've missed
anything there no I don't think you
really have I mean and I want you to
tell me if you think I know I really
don't think you have like the the the
only reason we know and I said this on
our on fireside chats was the only
reason we know who Richard Spencer is is
because the media told us who Richard
Spencer was I had never heard of this
man before and i've been i've been
circulating in right-wing politics and
in kurtz every politics for a very long
time and i heard that name and then they
creakin gloated when when he got punched
and that made him more of a victim and
more pop and that was and i was very
vocal vociferous ly vocal about the fact
that like you got to keep your hands to
yourself i don't care what the guy says
you know don't you can't do that right
and that open up a whole new can torture
people that word people running around
with with violent tendencies and all
those kinds of things it's like no
that's nothing even a political thing
just keep your hands to yourself the
left has the media in its corner much of
the media in its corner and much of the
establishment in its corner so it's just
a more powerful entity which is why I
think that the the fact that this battle
is being waged by the Joe Rogan's and
the Dave Reubens and the Ben Shapiro's
and stuff and more independent and kind
of smaller outlets doing real war with
the CNN to the MSNBC's of the world and
the Young Turks of the world and stuff
like that is actually a pretty awesome
David and Goliath story from my
perspective because we do have the
numbers we have the support you know and
and I think that so I think you're right
it bothers me a great deal when people
criticize you for not having the proper
guests on or not I I like that you get
people enough rope to hang themselves by
the way I just sent out a list last week
of like 15 progressives I'd love to have
on the show it was retweeted at least a
thousand or two thousand times none of
them have respond worse people to put a
gun to their heads and force them to be
in this chair I know you so maybe I have
an advantage that a lot of other people
don't right to be fair but I know what's
in your heart and I know who you are and
I know what you want to do and I know
what you're about so I know that you
would have a year's worth of Rubin
reports with just liberals if they would
come on the show isn't it funny when you
read some of these things about people
that you know and it's like wow like
there's that's the I guess that's why
it's so intimate for us because we know
the people so if you're that if you're
just someone watching this and you you
are completely passionate about these
ideas and you know all of the work that
all of these people have done and all
that
but if you don't actually know the
person there's still a little disconnect
there but because so many of us now know
each other right they forced us all
together
basically they forced these strange
allies you know as I said in my first DM
of the year 2018 is gonna be the year of
unusual alliances well what has happened
Sam Harris and Ben Shapiro who disagree
on literally everything literally
everything are now Alex right I mean
that shows you what's going on because
they believe in the freedom of thought
freedom of speech these foundational
things that are being eroded by the
extremes it's just not only one of those
extremes really has power you know any
of this stuff about and we've talked
about this ad nauseam I need this stuff
about fascism or far-right rising in the
Unites States an other kind somebody
this is insane yeah anyone who knows
anything about the history of the Weimar
Republic and Nazi Germany wouldn't see a
[ __ ] single parallel here so I don't
know what you're talking about I'm much
more afraid of what's going on on the
other side but here's the thing yeah
right
people like to tether I've been a big
advocate for Trump voters even though
I'm not a trump voter and even automatic
from supporter because I think they've
been maligned and called stupid and
moronic and all those kinds of things
and I think that we need to need to
treat people that we disagree with like
people like I said earlier and I feel
the same way about Bernie Sanders
supporters Bernie Sanders hasn't said
one cogent a reasonable thing I've ever
heard of I think the guy's a total
[ __ ] loon yeah but I think the people
that that listen to him and like him are
worthy of respect
worthy of you know being listened to and
understanding that they've reached those
conclusions based on things that maybe I
don't understand her I don't see eye to
eye with oh yeah we have to just be I
think a little bit more reasonable what
the far left doesn't like is that
they're the new evangelical right they
don't like that they don't like being
called that but it's true
and I know that's not necessarily unique
thing to say but they're the new
evangelicals they're the ones that are
it was funny we're talking about games
before and back there was a back in the
90s when the ers RB the ratings board
came to bay this wasn't because like the
night track and mortal kombat yeah and
the people that were in my deep before
you go for it sure I did while I was in
a fight with a guy in at school Willits
in Syosset and I did rip a guy's head
off and rip his spine out oh that's
funny too right and blood was good and
the tipper gore was all do it Mortal
Connor no no no you that's just how you
fight that's my thing you know it was it
was partially or mostly evangelical it's
the same thing with D&D actually be
traced it to the 80s evangelical
right-wing family's values groups were
the ones that were trying to shut this
stuff down now they had Lieberman and
Gore on there
but these were moderate establishment
Democrats the same people that are
trying to shut games down today the
people that are trying to scrub violence
and sexuality and all these terrible
things terrible things that are
happening in video games are left-wing
people they're the new it's their
identity politics are it's just that
they're they're the Christian right of
the eighties and it's like really weird
to see how they become what they hate
you know ours are supposed to hate so I
when you talk about sam harris and you
talk about ben shapiro are these really
great thinkers I've been listening a lot
of sam Harris's show recently and it's
you know what I've been playing games
and it's just so great even if I don't
agree with everything relating to that
calming voice while you're playing video
games that sound fourteen and he has
such a great audio gate on his
microphone that I'll wear it just it's
just the perfect sound the fact that
these people are getting together I
think is a great sign because it's
people understanding that there's a
foundational erosion there's nothing
everything a built on it doesn't matter
if the foundational erosion of freedoms
of expression freedoms of speech
what's going on with the guy in Scotland
that got fined for that you know that's
insane yeah that anyone of any ilk would
think that something like that is okay
that shows that we have a foundational
erosion so guys like that getting
together great news did you see this
freaking tweet by the Yorkshire police
about this guy that they're putting in
jail for eight months because he drove
through a like of toll and it was caught
on video giving the finger to the toll
and they said don't you it was something
like don't they we think it was a real
threat like don't do this or you'll end
up in jail too
all the guy did was give the toll the
finger it's on the British I think maybe
he was speeding but either way you're
gonna be spent eight months in jail I
mean the British Twitter accounts for
the cop like that the police
organizations are amazing like they're
like I I can't tell if some of them are
fake that's how I know can I like there
was one where I think it was real where
they're like look at all the knives we
took on the street I'm like no you're
going after people's knives yeah like
this this is something you're tweeting
about and I think one of them tweet
about how they took all this marijuana
or something I'm like I would have
smoked that marijuana so I tweeted them
you can't do anything to me British
police yeah I can't touch me but there
is Dave there's and I think you would
agree that there's just a foundational
erosion that I think people of all sides
and I think there's totally
intellectually smart people on the far
left that can help that where are those
people there's a there's a there's a
youtuber that I'm actually quite
interest
in that I watch her and I don't mean the
misgender hugger lady I think she
identifies as our contrapposto know if
you've heard of this of this youtuber
who's on the far left seeing the name
come up every now and again on Twitter
totally disagree with everything this
person says but I look at it I'm like
this seems very reasonable educated
academic and I so I'm seeing reasons to
hope that everyone's gonna come together
I know that that seems to be a theme of
what I'm saying but I just in order to
sharpen our knives and load our guns we
have to soften a little bit so that when
we when we get involved in the things
we're getting involved and trying to
change really matter as opposed to
fighting every [ __ ] fight how much do
you think it's just that we don't
understand we as Americans here don't
understand how good we have it but to me
it almost seems that at any great shift
we could have right now like yes could
there be some like massive shift really
towards freedom and free thought and we
all start being nicer to each other and
taller and I suppose something like that
could happen there and as I said I think
there's pieces of it but because so much
of this political correctness stuff is
crumbling but maybe there is some
interesting second enlightenment
happening somehow in the future
something maybe but it seems to me that
if something was to really break like if
we had a real movement one way or
another it would go the other way which
would be much worse yeah our freedoms
would be much more restricted and that
our ability to communicate would be a
lot more difficult and and all that I
mean I would I would literally maybe not
literally but I would that's the kind of
thing where there are so many people
like me and you I would go down fighting
to make sure that that didn't happen
like that that would be that would be a
klaxon call that you couldn't possibly
ignore it's the same thing like when
people told there are certain realities
that are never gonna happen
what is that in you why is that what do
you mean why I know you're telling me
the truth right I know you always tell
the truth but I know you're telling me
the truth right now like you would fight
for it you would where do you think that
comes from and you I think I asked you
this once before maybe maybe on the
livestream right in the midst of that
craze I don't know I mean I think a lot
of that I think is just I want salute I
think some people like the combat yeah
right and so that's they perpetuate it
they want it to never end and I don't
like the combat I'm just ready for it
you know like I'm not talking about a
violent revolution or anything I'm
talking literally about
an idea a battle of ideas right and I
really do believe that we're fighting
too many fights we're just it muddies
the water but that's such an existential
fight you know if if someone really is
gonna come after the first amendment I'm
not worried I know a lot people worry
about the second member there never no
one's ever coming for your guns it's
impossible what caused the revolution it
will cause us of war so that's never
gonna happen
but these these these more style revisit
that when we have the civil war civil
war - yeah but there are certain things
that you have to just stand up and say
like no no if that thing happened in the
United States so what happens in the UK
is not my it's interesting but it's not
my concern
seemingly brexit I would've voted for
Bragg's it but whatever do what you got
to do but if that kind of thing that
happen to that that what is thank you
love ya countdown together if that
happened here that would be a big thing
to me like a much bigger thing I can't
have that kinda stuff can't happen here
and if it does then we then we do
something about it but we those are the
kinds of again foundational elements
those fights that we have to have that I
think are really important and
everything else is a distraction you
know it's interesting a couple weeks ago
I was speaking in Boston at a turning
point this young college conservative
group they invite me I tell them my
differences with them and they still dig
it and there was a guy there who I had
met who makes these giant
replications of the Bill of Rights and
the Constitution huge ones he gave me
two of them were gonna we're gonna put
him on their board they're being framed
right now is but they're gonna be either
in the studio or a screening room he's
huge huge so I go on the plane with them
and I have this you know they're rolled
up I got these two huge Bill of Rights
Constitution right there it's a have it
in the overhead thing and I'm flying
back and I'm watching the darkest hour
which is the Winston Churchill so I'm
watching this movie and I just spoke to
all of these kids for an hour about
freedom I got the bill of rights in the
Constitution I'm watching this thing
Churchill and you know Hitler's on the
march thing they think the country is
gonna crumble the king and the royal
family is thinking about moving to
Canada I mean it really was that dire
and all of these appeasers around
Winston Churchill you know I mean all of
these guys from Chamberlain on Danner
and all of the people plotting against
him and thinking we can negotiate with
Hitler and now maybe France or Belgium
will fall but we'll be okay
and I sort of think that's what we're in
right now that what you just said is I
will stand here
we'll stand here and I will put my flag
in it and this will be the hill that I
will I will go down on and I think maybe
that's what's happening we're getting a
braver group of people now and I'm proud
to be in that in that group yeah yeah
this is the I don't know what happened I
don't know what had the reason I ask you
what happened to you or what is it about
you I don't know what the hell happened
to me that put me here it's I don't know
I genuinely have no idea I know they
call red pilling and I like that term
because it's it's it's true in the sense
you know I'm not one of these guys that
uses a lot of the other you know the
[ __ ] in the yesterday W and snowflake
cuz I feel like that could just be
totally turned around and you like I
said the identity politics exist on both
sides but that term red pilling really
makes sense because some people really
just see reality for what it is right
and all these other arguments are
distractions to these you know you could
probably identify if we sat down and
really thought about it
you probably identified four or five
hills that are worth dying on right and
I certainly think that something like
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression is like that's like the inner
keep you can't let that fall that's it
you know and so I think that you were
saying that there's an awakening I think
that a lot of it is up people are just
getting smarter they're just they're
educating themselves maybe they're
educating themselves in the other
direction which is their right but we
are a more literate society a more
curious society and all those kinds of
we have more open to us and available to
us than we ever did so it's up to people
to kind of solve these problems for
themselves and I really do believe that
our numbers sometimes seem smaller than
they really are and I really do believe
that sometimes their numbers seem bigger
than they are I really do I really do
believe that I know well we're on our
way all right we've done like an hour
twenty already oh okay yeah let's do
some Q&A with the good show out there of
the Internet sure I'd love that would
you do an uncensored Q&A which I in sit
in fact I wanted to be so uncensored I'm
gonna get naked and we're gonna and
we're gonna do it fully uncensored and
you're gonna get definitely do mine you
think we're putting this thing on
pornhub or porn tube or porn send anyone
porn now or tear it down with keep it
and send it wherever you okay people
uncensored QA obviously patrons
patreon.com/scishow and report you're
gonna get first priority super chat
right here on
on YouTube and then we'll take some
Facebook questions and alright give us
two minutes just to make sure you know
our heads are on straight
maybe pour this guy a glass of whiskey
or something and just hang on two
minutes we'll be right back
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
alright guys we are back I think we
actually did two minutes there I always
say one minute then it ends up being six
minutes people start getting pissed yeah
they get a little antsy yes I still have
my clothes on sorry everyone you have
your clothes on or your wall we wanted
to bust out a joint yep I don't know
about the ventilation that's not urine
yeah we'll see what we can do perhaps
that seems more of a periscope act it's
alright we got a ton of good stuff here
so yeah if you're on patreon we're gonna
look at your stuff for a super chat
Facebook whatever you want to do alright
so first Colin's mom just wanted to say
hi glad to see you two together and she
used a clapping emoji she's she's an
emoji master yeah yeah Moriarty yeah
she's I love how I'm such a mother's boy
and I love how engaged she is with my
content like she's just in the community
and it's awesome well I wish everyone
can experience exits she's like my
biggest fan it's so cool that is very
cool alright until the thing friend
infringes on me or gets rubbed in my
face I think totally the same way Colin
does yeah I mean live in let lips that
wasn't a question alright super chat hi
Dave Colin is one of our heroes as we
study game design I make an essay point
that minorities love video games despite
the quote under-representation people
empathize with video games differently
than movies or books hash tag not your
shield yet now your shield is an old
hash tag that was associated with a
gamer game by the way I didn't really
like gamergate either I was saying I was
saying some of the salient points that
people still bring up about identity
politics and stuff along before
gamergate you can go back and read [ __ ]
on IGN from 10 years ago I was writing
about that well let's remember that
gamergate really hurt a lot of people
and I think that people need to kind of
remember that it was a really
destructive and not effective way of
getting your message across yeah totally
stand with that but and it it also
showed the power of a community in the
right sense of a community a community
based in individuals who weren't gonna
take [ __ ] from the power structure
that was relentlessly attacking them
right in the name of political
correctness it's actually what I mean
gamergate has just leaked into
everything that's what people say is
that that was really the beginning of
like the rise of Trump I don't know I
don't know if you would there's because
probably multiple tethers that I wasn't
aware of at that time that were also
connecting from things that I was I was
I'm in this fandom so I remember that
yeah but yeah it's something began there
but people need to figure out a
different
to effectively get their message across
because I don't think that was it this
is very important from super chat what
is Collins position on warping levels in
Mario Brothers I mean if you're
speedrunning it's a it's a necessity but
I like doing a clean run of 1 1 2 8 4 in
Mario it's very hard a lot of people
can't do it yeah 3 is tough yeah oh yes
with all the hammer brothers yeah and
then eight more obviously is like with
the puzzle yeah yeah you got a yeah
sometimes you're going up sometimes your
heads all about speed like especially on
eight three if you could just run you
hop or like let them jump over you know
the hammer brothers it's a tough that's
a tougher game than people remember I
laugh at them I feel like I'm this is
impresses me but I probably won't
impress you but when I think I was a
sophomore in college I had a friend Mike
Sherman great guy Binghamton University
who beat Super Mario Brothers warped he
just wanted to see how quick he could
beat at max warps nine minutes yeah I
think that I think the record is right
around there like maybe a few minutes
less than that yeah cuz people can go
you can beat it pretty quickly if you
warp starting with one two orbs warps
what a world
let's see Colin what do you think of a
new god of war I'm said there are no sex
scenes not just because of ran deenis
but also found them artistic in past
games it's great I have a video review
of oh you just did one yeah I did a
video review of it but on my youtube
channel one of my youtube channels and I
think it's really great it's a different
direction for God of War God of War was
very Arkady very ps2 era
Kratos as a protagonist not very deep
this game took five years for them to
make and they really they really they
fixed everything there's some problems
with it but I don't it's got like an
amazing 95 or 96 i Metacritic I don't
think it's that good but it's it's great
patreon next question just want to say
thanks to Colin for introducing me to
the Rubin report been a proud patron of
the to you since then infamous tweet
from last year so thank you let's jump
back to super chat Dave you've talked
about how the left is coming for Asians
next would like to ask the two of you
why Asians still vote and associate left
and how do we change that also how do we
balance identity politics with kinship I
like the second part I mean real quick
on on the Asian thing we sort of hit on
this already but if you're going to have
quotas of we're going to have a certain
amount of people based on color or based
on some other immutable characteristic
that have to get in you're going to harm
the people who what work the hard it not
nice
they work the hardest who if there's a
group that's over-represented by working
the hardest and succeeding the most in
becoming the most educated which in many
cases is the Asian community then they
are going to be directly hurt so
identity politics is actually in us
because it's an assault on success right
so if you're gonna say we're gonna keep
helping these people it doesn't just
magically happen it comes at the expense
of someone else there's only a certain
amount of jobs there's only a certain
amount of slots at universities and
things of that nature is that so yes
someone's got to lose they're somewhat
right I mean that's what they never tell
you right it all sounds good but the
interesting thing about asian-americans
voting liberal I was thinking recently
about remember Proposition 8 yeah I
don't think ilding California thought no
I was Proposition 8 for people that
don't know was the gay marriage of kind
of proposition in 2008 when Obama was on
the the ballot now remember Obama won
that year pretty easily California Prop
8 was voted down gay marriage remained
illegal in California not because of
white liberal voters it actually was
voted down by black liberal voters and
Hispanic liberal voters who have
conservative or religious kind of
conscience in those sorts of things so
again it's just an example of how
complicated it is beyond skin color and
what horseshit intersectionality is
absolutely yeah because it was not your
your your oppressions don't make you
stronger they actually make you in
competition with the people that you're
supposedly in right and go check the
numbers everyone by the way there's fast
that the numbers on Prop 8 are
fascinating hey Colin do you longtime
fan do you think that Nintendo is a true
competitor right now at the switch and
does the future look good for them just
real quick on that I mean I'm loving the
switch like it's the video game system
that I was supposed to find right whole
time it's great I think that they're
gonna plateau on sales over the next
couple years because I think they blew
their load already with Zelda and Mario
they had to do that so they were in a
position where you know we--you was
terrible it's a terrible console and
they were getting killed but ps4 is and
and and to an extent Xbox one but ps4
certainly I think it still trouncing and
overall numbers worldwide but I said
that switch would sell twice as many
units as Wii U and think they're gonna
exceed that and it's a nice step in the
right direction I just don't know if
they have the software at the cadence
that they're gonna need it over the next
four or five years and remember I mean I
can tell you I have sources ps5 games
are in development PS fives not that far
away and that thing's gonna make the
switch look like a child's toy so
they're going
to deal with that intergenerational kind
of conflict as well right but Nintendo
kind of thrives on that right like
having a little of that
intergenerational stuff they do but with
Hardware being so much weaker I mean the
hardware now switch is still weaker than
ps4 and Xbox one so they're getting
ports of games that are doom is a good
example that ran at 60 frames on ps4
that's running at 30 frames on switch
the difference between the games on the
next generation it's which are gonna be
even more market I'm curious and they're
basically developers and publishers
gonna have to make the same game twice
basically as opposed to porting it so I
wonder if there's gonna be some
complications there as well so I think
it's looking great right now I love it
yeah I'm so pleased that it's selling
well and the Nintendo fans needed a win
I just love that I can be playing on the
television and then just like if I got
to get up or if David wants to watch TV
or something I can just take that thing
and go into the room it's very cool I
mean it's a very very slick piece either
Bryan on patreon why are you guys
continuing to use Twitter why continue
to give that platform support your
followers slash patrons will follow you
elsewhere and share your content from
new locations so why stay and allow bad
actors to benefit from your presence I'd
like to answer that one but I'll throw
it to you first I just feel like I have
to be where the audience is yeah it's
like yeah we can we can work on things
that we've discussed and I think there's
a lot of discussions happening it's not
just us about what are the alternatives
to Twitter to Facebook to YouTube yeah
you'd lose a bet but you'd right but at
the moment you know we need we need to
go where the people are yeah to me
Twitter although I have no doubt that
shadow banning exists and I actually
just DM Jack about it this morning
because I don't I simply don't see
tweets him I never see your tweets
anymore oh really I I only see your
tweets when you add my why I won't ever
see Phil DeFranco all the YouTube crew
that I used to kind of be part of the
the Laci green and Raygun and some black
guy all those guys I don't see any of
their tweets anymore
I see a lot of the politics people all
the time so I just you know it look I
don't have the evidence extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
cross Sagan it's over there somewhere I
don't know yeah I don't have the
document in front of me but it's like
you and a lot of times I think it's
subtly because it's not that they've
written a something out there like a
memo is going down for a jack all the
way down I think it's just engineers
that's for sure it's it's guys at
YouTube
messing around with the algorithm so
well that our videos don't go out to the
feeds why did literally hundreds of
people keep telling me they're being
unsubscribed and then when I tell
YouTube that what they tell me is that
people don't know how to click the
subscribe button or they were never
subscribed in the first place people I
literally know that are not eating
that's always someone else yeah it's
always yeah I mean I'll graders I think
my biggest concern is YouTube Twitter
and Facebook you know whatever YouTube
is a essential in their their their
[ __ ] with a lot of stuff is is
becoming too much to bear and by the way
CLS and CLS side-quests
are totally fine by the way most most of
time with monetization like I have no
problems and some of the you know even
with some of the contentious political
stuff I put up so it's I think it's just
that you are big and you're and you're
clearly being targeted I mean I think
they're lying if they say otherwise oh I
like this question laughs this is from
super Chet are there any stances you
currently hold that you'd consider your
weakest or close to flipping on I'll let
you go first though that yeah I think
the pro-life pro-choice thing is is I am
I am very vehement about a lot of my
views and that's the one I can that's
the one where not only I can see the
other side understand the other side I
can see myself being on the other side
and that's the only and you were on the
others yeah I was I just again it's just
a conundrum it's a cosmic [ __ ]
conundrum it's not X plus y equals Z or
something like that it's way more
complicated so that's why I take a more
nuanced approach yeah I mean for real
that was the one I was gonna say - I
that's why I say the word for grudgingly
when I say I'm pro-choice and and even
David and I have a difference of opinion
on this where he doesn't he's not
thrilled when I say but grudgingly and
he's got a really interesting nuanced
position on this but it's one of those
ones you're right I like that you said
it's a cosmic conundrum this isn't about
law what we're talking about this is if
because it goes to the root of the
biggest questions of the universe and
life and all that so it's the one where
I mean I would for anyone watching this
that wants to know further and watch my
chat with Shapiro about it like I admit
that the 20-week thing it's somewhat
arbitrary of course I'm not saying it's
not a life at 18 weeks they've done
studies where they believe the fetus can
feel pain at 20 weeks so I'm picking
that position but yes if I'm saying it's
life at 20 is it life at 18 it is in
which case what level of that slippery
slope and then you have extremists on
the other side who say you can abort an
eight month baby if you don't want I
mean that's an
murder that that's true I agree if my
whole thing is like once the baby can
really exist even with medical care
outside of the womb I mean that's that's
a game over for any any and you know but
again it's like you gotta it's tough man
and a lot of it you know the
Conservatives it's easy to be pro-life
but then take sex ed and contraception
out of schools and put kids in positions
where they they have to make these kinds
of decisions it's much Laci green talks
a lot about this it's much more
complicated than then again this binary
position so yeah
patreon is the Star Wars franchise a
lost cause yes I can't believe I'm gonna
agree with you but I think it might be
but I'll have one caveat you want to go
any further first I just think that solo
movies probably to be terrible and III
think too much of a good thing is is
that's a saying for a reason and I would
have loved you know rogue one was great
and I know you don't why I know I didn't
like not like it boring name three
characters go oh I don't know any of the
names of the character I win but I like
how they how they're all dead at the end
I like how they were all gonna die at
the end it was just my whole thing is
like I would have just taken a new
trilogy name one character and it can't
be Darth Vader oh I am talking I don't
know yeah but I thought you were walking
out of the original Star Wars who is
that guy dressed in black what was that
yeah I mean come on you're that's a
totally fair point yeah I know is there
but I think that it's the same thing
with marble like I can't I'm not I'm not
I don't really like Marvel movies anyway
I don't like the whole like weird
superhero thing that's not for me yeah
but it's too much it's creatively devoid
and I'd rather see new ideas than have
to like go back to the well and just
regurgitate and resuscitate all this
[ __ ] over and over again well you you
know well I'm sure that everyone has
seen this online but in LA here on
Sunset Boulevard there is this massive
billboard for Avengers for the new one
infinity war and it looks like the Star
Wars ones you know what I mean where
they have them all sort of facing out
looking at another it's like did you
guys literally just copy I get Marvel
owns both the unit but are you is that
what you're doing you're gonna literally
just brand these all the same as for
Star Wars look I loved force awakens I
think it's pretty damn perfect it was
yes was it a little derivative what's
the amount that they had to lift but JJ
had to do two
reboot that bringing the old actors tie
it all together get people to forget the
prequels III think it was pretty freakin
perfect last Jedi when I saw it on
theater I walked out of there I felt
like I got like punched in the gut there
were so many inconsistencies not
explaining who Snoke is that ridiculous
scene at the casino yeah that was that
that that was straight out of the
prequels man I mean just so stupid and I
mean the whole who's Benicio del Toro I
still don't explain it they don't
explain anything what a what a waste
what's his name Captain phasma turns out
to be like pointless that was a shame
because I thought they were really gonna
do something with her rey finn should
have died at the end Howdy's dying in
his blaze of glory then he doesn't die
and then like the random the random one
and then the random girl and like that
was there was also a social justice the
element that was kind of gross why was
lurid purple-haired laura dern that
should have been akbar you just
introduced us to a character we don't
care about it should have been Akbar
right like he's aging he's led the
rebels murder they kill they kill him
off-screen why not have it be him that
turns the ship around people would have
literally been hysterically crying and
instead they do that anyway I saw I
walked out I hated it then I went back
with my I surprised my seven-year-old
nephew with my brother and and because I
was with a kid who still has that magic
I walked out of there and I liked it
more i watch it on a plane about two
weeks ago and it's bad ya know even the
one seen in Snoke Slayer which was
awesome the flow with the world are yeah
the end it ended and you're like alright
that's it I mean it was just it was
really like Ryan Johnson just doesn't
like Star Wars
he doesn't like Luke Skywalker Luke was
a grumpy do it and more casting the Mark
Hamill hate like Mark Hamill yeah
but basically I shockingly spoken about
that how he doesn't he didn't seem to
like them I had to unfollow Mark Hamill
yeah Witter he's got a little social
justice yeah I never my I never followed
him to begin with I couldn't take it but
I well I will say this real quick about
about Star Wars I think that it's I
think you know rewind this of YouTube
still exists in 20 years you're gonna
regret what they're about to do to Star
Wars I really feel that way like and by
the way one of the things I'm trying to
do with fireside chats my pocket my the
obverse a tional podcast is I'm trying
to one I try to have people I know or
big guests on I just had
Kelly Carlin on you on yeah but I'm also
having people it for my audience on all
they have to do is message me on patreon
and pitch me something and so I've had a
few people on about that cuz I like to
raise these kind of smaller voices
tomorrow I'm having a survivalist on
which is all how's that what a great
episode nice and one of them that I'm
recording in two weeks is a kid or a guy
a film student reshot means like I want
to defend the prequels and I'm like come
on over I didn't you know what I'm gonna
listen to it obviously but I think
they're defendable and after watching
last Jedi again I was longing for them
in a way at least the put the acting
aside put some of the stiff dialogue
aside the stories are there yeah alright
alright I'm being told that a lot of
people in the chat think you're a Jew
you are from Long Island yep you are
Italian I'm Italian I'm half of town my
mom's Italian my dad's Irish yeah so it
makes sense I I've often said and I mean
it I feel like I am an honorary Jew I've
seen the paperwork for well people long
islands an interesting place you know
because you're from there it's
incredibly Jewish and incredibly Italian
yeah we're the only place that gets Rosh
Hashanah off and all these kinds of yeah
October was like a [ __ ] goldmine for
you it was awesome yeah Columbus Day we
got off so yeah everything October was
and my birthday's in October so
everything was great in October yeah but
there's something about Long Island
culture that is inherently Jewish and
like I knew people that wouldn't get
into like I straight-up knew people that
would not get into German cars like
families right like that's how serious
it was and so I have a kinship to Jewish
people based on on that experience and
so I consider that kind of like the
ought the the non-genetic part of me no
and I have a kinship to Italians which
is why we had you here to make the
homemade gravy yeah that we made the
gravy the eight-hour gravy we you make
us seriously you liked it yeah I mean
there was not a leftover well there were
some what there was that night but I
assure you they were gone the next day
perfect you done well right out of right
out of Goodfellas
okay thanks thanks for introducing me to
Colin and was wondering if you see a
parallel between what happened to Colin
and Owen Benjamin
are you following Owen Benjamin I don't
know if I know the situation well
basically he's a comedian who admittedly
like goes to where the line is and
intentionally jumps over I've had him on
the show I like him
I don't see a real parallel because I
think you go out of your way to be
respectful where I'm not saying he's not
respectful but he's intentionally trying
to poke the bear it's just a different
thing I happen to like both of you but I
don't really see it yeah I I want to say
just to clear things up for people that
are listening that might be curious well
some people think that I did that tweet
intentionally is like an exit like an
escape you know
hatch from kind of fun because I wasn't
happy there and I wasn't happy there but
that I never did it to hurt anyone
so yeah that's true I I don't really try
to like do anything I don't I don't
target individuals that's a big thing
for me yeah unless they're a politician
so well I do find that most of us on
this side of it if I can use that term
really try not to how often do you find
anyone on my show really rant you know
ransacking and attacking a specific
person we constantly are talking about
ideas and yet we're dealing with the set
of people who are constantly attacking
us as people they're separate so I'll
just condense a few here a lot of people
are asking about your relationship with
the kind of funny staff anything you
want to comment on that no I mean I am
you know a lot of the a lot of the past
year has been about grappling with
what's happened and kind of did I fight
hard enough to the for the soul of the
company did I give people enough
information to let them know what was
really happening there and there's an
eagerness for me to do that cuz I think
people would see my side if they just
knew more but I'm I've put that to bed
in my mind I've forgiven like what I
feel like has been done to me from that
situation from the people that I think
have done things to me from that
situation and as far as Greg is
concerned who's kind of you know was my
best friend for many years I reached out
to him a couple months ago totally
that's odd it kind of funny I have no
interest you know I mean I'd be
perfectly happy to be on one of the
shows but that's not the reason I I
don't really care if I don't do any kind
of funny stuff anymore
but I reached out to Greg as a person
just to be like look you know I'm you
know what's let's talk we have this
friendship that far predates any of this
stuff and he wasn't really interested in
talking to me so really I but that I'm
sorry to interrupt but the the thing I
want to say is that someone approached
me and was like if something happens to
him you're gonna be you know [ __ ]
happens every day he gets in a car crash
you get he had cancer he gets sick you
were gonna be full of regret for the
rest of your life that you didn't bury
this hatchet you can't control the
outcome but at least extend the hand and
so I did that big weight lifted off my
shoulders can't do anything else about
it and
you know wish them to wish them the very
best yeah you can't grab one I don't
know that you'll want me to say this
publicly but in the midst of all that
was all happening and I was really just
getting to know you in the middle of
that you made it so clear to me how you
wanted to make sure that you didn't
throw them under the bus in the process
of that and I think a lot of people
would not have taken my no I've never
wanted to do that I mean like I've never
wanted to get talked about
individual relationships and the way
things broke down from an individual
standpoint because I don't think it's
really anyone's business yeah you know
it's I know that a lot of people witness
that but I don't unless we're all around
to tell that story one day and if in the
most fair way possible I don't think
it's really you know there's a night but
I but I've forgiven and moved on this is
on patreon and there's been a couple
like this do you have any advice on
having a career in an industry where
you're an ideological minority you were
able to be as successful in games
journalism but how did you find a
balance between saying what you think
and not rocking the boat so that you so
that it hurts your career well that's a
great question I think that you know I
often talk about how weaving kind of
funny was someone easy because I wasn't
happy there but leaving IGN before that
was really hard and I really loved that
job and I look back at it very fondly
and one of the reasons that I love that
I'm actually having
yeah glitch in the matrix just happened
and I don't know what I don't know what
they heard what they didn't know was all
the good stuff I gave you guys the whole
secret and then but all I was trying to
say to the recap is IGN was very good to
me they never tried to shut me up you
need to find people that understand who
you are also understand that old media
is waning and dying being in the
in-crowd with them is irrelevant and I'm
you know there's certain sites that
still get it like IGN but there are many
sites like polygon Waypoint stuff that
won't even exist in a few years and that
the game development and publishing
scene is way more politically vibrant
it's just that a lot of those people are
unwilling to say it because they are
concerned and I brought up that game
Kingdom Come deliverance to that where
the more the press went after that game
the more it's sold and I the one thing
that I forgot to say that it sold like a
million copies in like a few days and I
tweeted out publicly where I was like I
wonder when publishers are gonna figure
out that by getting on the bad side of
Kotaku bad side of Waypoint the bad side
of all these sites that they're gonna
sell more copies of games but there's
way more ideological and I'm not gonna
out anyone I'm from good friends with a
lot of people and publishing and
developing that are libertarian
Republican Trump voters they're there
they're just quiet yeah
all right here's what we're gonna do I'm
talking directly to the camera on the
chance that YouTube is gonna blow up
again or the glitch in the matrix is
going to get us will do as many will do
a bunch more here and then we'll do
everything else in rapid-fire on patreon
and and cons on the patreon too so let's
just do a couple more here hey Dave as a
Hispanic female and a migrant from Texas
to Michigan racism jokes are not mostly
comes from Mexicans and it's hilarious
why is it hard for whites to laugh at
themselves on the left I mean it's a
good question it's like they've become
hysterical for everyone else right
because they think that makes them moral
and actually I think it's it's what
everyone now says this phrase it's the
small bigotry of low expectations you
think that you must be offended for
everybody no one else can take a joke so
you must take offense no one else can
accomplish anything so you must help
everyone and actually what you're what
you're doing is belittling them in in
many cases and I wonder what way as I'm
getting back into stand-up now it's like
I wonder what would happen to Don
Rickles these days who did it with love
but he
be and then but then there were guys
like I love Anthony Jeselnik who is like
super [ __ ] inappropriate and he
manages to thrive I saw ricky gervais
slive at Dolby theatre a couple months
ago and he goes into this whole thing
and I think it's actually reflected in
his Netflix special I think it's
probably the same thing a lot of
transgender jokes and all that kind of
stuff and when I was surprised by was
that there were a few groans and stuff
like that but people were laughing and
clapping and having a good time here in
Liberal Los Angeles I think it goes to
show you that people know how to laugh
at themselves and I actually think it's
what it's actually extremely racist to
think that you need to be offended on
some other person's behalf because they
can't be offended for themselves yeah
yeah and they can't tell you you need to
tell them what they're supposed to feel
it's a little strange and obviously
Candace is going through it oddly it
oddly is racism that is racist this is a
good one because it gets to a lot of
what we were talking about earlier how
do you grade someone's motivation when
President Trump says quote sending their
best why would it necessarily mean the
smartest the brightest and most
successful well I think I would need to
know the exact quotes that he has said
but I've heard him say they're not
sending us are their best in the context
of meaning they're not sending us their
most educated or people that can help
Society in that way but as far as
grading someone's motivation I would say
I really try not to impugn people's
motivations I mean how people mock me
for it how often on this show do I say
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions I mostly you said it earlier
I mean I mostly believe that these
misguided people are misguided not evil
are there evil actors are there bad
actors are there manipulators for sure
so I think you have to really try hard
not to do it but we all we all do it
yeah I mean I I look at it similar to
what you were saying about Ellis Island
and all that earlier I want the most
desperate people like I don't mean that
in like they're escaping war escaping
something you know some crime or
something like that I want the people
that are like hungry even if they have
no education and no money in their
pockets my family came the Moriarty's
came over in the 1850s and the first
thing that one of them did when they
came over Timothy I think his name was
was he signed up for the Union Army you
know in 1861 and when my Italian family
came over in the 20s in the 1920s in
1930s they had [ __ ] nothing
yeah and they made something out of
themselves those are the kinds of people
that are the fabric of America we don't
want your bioengineers
we want your your uneducated migrant
labor with with two kids and trying to
trying to strive to do something right
that's great look we could take all your
academics from over there but our
colleges are collapsing under the weight
of their own [ __ ] right right and
you don't want to be educated here
anywhere I got out of college just in
the nick of time
super chat Colin very happy he came on
the Rubin report net have never heard of
you before today Konica a disgrace we
agree on many things aside from Trump
Trump seems more American than any
assume he means any president since JFK
why don't you like him so the thing is
there's a lot that Trump says that I do
like
but you and I've had this conversation
many times privately over dinner and
drinks and obviously copious amount of
weed I don't stand by anything I've said
I know I sometimes don't remember some
of that's 2 a.m. but I I look at Trump
as a guy who's simply an ineffective
messenger no matter how even if you won
reelection in 2020 which is possible I
guess I don't think is gonna run again I
stand by that but even if you won
there's he's still so inherently
divisive whether it's fair or not I
think a lot of it is fair I think he is
a divisive person wouldn't you rather
have someone in there with some of the
same ideas or most of the same ideas but
is a more effective messenger I think
that that's all it is it's not it's not
really a characterization of him as a
person or his ideas and necessarily I
think you have some bad ideas I think
it's just like you need someone that can
work with people you need and that's why
I love that you had John Kasich on if
John Kasich runs in primaries Trump I'm
voting for John Kasich yeah but he'll
never win I mean I didn't want to say
that to his face I thought he was a
really nice guy but the system you know
this is the the line I keep using about
you know you wanted a panther in a china
shop to knock over a couple things
believe the china shop buy that no such
thing as a panther in attractive young
get a bull in a china shop but what I
would say to your point though in on the
hopeful side if you want some values
that you really believe to be instilled
in the president going forward is that
the chaos right now in the Kayne
situation and all of it it is all
connected and I believe out of the chaos
maybe a same conservative you know a ben
shapiro type conservative who i'm sure
you have some differences with but that
is great yeah that type of conservative
will be able to grow out of this like
this this special case of trump whatever
you want to call that that thing can't
sustain itself forever like it just
can't but what has he done I'm not
talking about tweets I'm not talking
character I'm not talking about mocking
everybody and all that but is there
something policy-wise that he's done
that you think is beyond the pale yeah I
thought that the travel we call the
travel ban I mean it's vernacular but I
thought that that was totally
unnecessary and it's the list which was
come up came up through the embalming
yes no absolutely no I don't deny that
at all I just think that it was it's
just it it's fuel on the fire when
you're supposed to be putting the fire
out politics is a game and to get what
you want you need to play the game
sometimes so this is something you want
to do this is something that you need to
kind of sneak in maybe after the
midterms not immediately just to piss
more people often have rallies at
[ __ ] airports and [ __ ] like that
so it's not you know I I believe I don't
necessarily know that we need a wall but
I believe in immigration control and I
go as far as to say that we need to
amend the Constitution to get rid of
birthright citizenship which by the way
is a totally uniquely American being
there's almost no first world country in
the world that does it yeah so there's
things like that where I'm like yeah
immigration reform great treating
veterans better of course those are
great things but again you need a better
messenger and I think that Kasich would
lose remember that the Reagan Ford
primary in 76 and the the the Carter
primary in 1980 both didn't work out
well for the incumbent I do think Trump
if he wins is gonna lose all runs rather
he's gonna lose that was if he wins he's
gonna lose he's already lost my way I
would never want to be present a
question for Colin why have you stopped
producing political historical videos on
the main Collins last an Channel there's
multiple reasons one is that I don't
feel like I was doing it the way that I
wanted to do it people so give me a
second I might Dave when I launched
Colin's last and people thought I was
gonna take the piss out of the SJW in
the snowflake and stuff will out people
that weren't familiar with me not
knowing that that's not really Who I am
and those aren't terms I use which is
why I led with the third amendment video
to be like this is what it's gonna be
and the viewership declined a little bit
but I wasn't even worried about that
because I don't really care about that
on patreon supported but I felt like it
was everything was turning into an
argument everything was turning into
like you can't just have a conversation
you can't just bring a point up I would
do a video about the Trump things that
Trump did wrong people that I'm around
with that I'd do a video about the Trump
things Trump did right people have a
problem with that so I was like you know
I got to step back from this focus on
the more gaming and culture centric
stuff that I'm doing with fireside chats
and side quests and figure out a way to
approach it
I'm going to announce specific details
soon but basically I'm probably gonna
bring the show back once a quarter
they're gonna be way longer and I'm
aiming for June to do the next one all
right very good
super chat talk about the how the trauma
from four hundred fifty years of slavery
and racism has caused blacks like Candis
and Kanye to marry white and join the
FoxNews chatterbox and this is just a
silly premise so are you saying that
black people shouldn't marry white
people should Asian people not marry
Latinos you know to me unless and the
iron you know this Fox News thing yes
does Candis go on Fox News yes who the
only one that will put me on of all the
networks is Fox News I don't get invites
to the others who defended Jordan
Peterson or who put Peterson on Fox News
who put brett weinstein on fox news so
you can say all you want about Fox News
and Hannity this and all that but it's
like who's consistently putting these
people on and who isn't right why wasn't
candy at Candis was on Fox this morning
why wasn't Candis on CNN or MSNBC I just
think there's some it's a great point
and the other thing is that just because
history terrible history and no one's
had a worse history in the United States
then then black people I mean there's no
doubt about that
but do you want to it's like what Candis
was saying I think she's a much more
effective messenger than me of course
but like do you just want to dwell in
that space or do you want to take
advantage of the fact that finally you
don't have to live in that space anymore
and your parents didn't and maybe your
grandparents didn't Jim Crow but like
that things are getting better like it's
an improvement I'm not saying it's
perfect I'm not a black man I don't know
what that thuds like to deal with and I
think that there are terrible things
happening in prisons and with cops and
all that kinds I've no doubt about it
but it's it's like we don't need to
fight those battles anymore we should
fight newer battles some abroad that
pointsme which i think is a great point
like abolitionists served an amazing
role in American history amazing role
beginning even before the Revolution
right up and through 1863 in 1865
ultimately you don't need abolitionists
today yeah
union organizers gave us the weekend and
the eight-hour work day a hundred years
ago you don't need them anymore now we
have it right so let's fight the new
battles that might be in the same spear
that might have overlap Venn diagram
overlap with those old things but we're
fighting old battles and it's keeping
you stuck in the past and that's a big
problem and I don't know why you'd
choose to do that to yourself you know
yeah all right
well here's what we're gonna do okay we
are going to end this stream you will
stay and answer the remaining questions
in rapid fire okay which means you got
to do it quick you know I'm not going to
I will I will yeah I'm going right to
your weakness yeah I know that pay my
Chili's exclusive rapper all right it's
been a pleasure brother a Zoey yeah
thank you for having me thank you for
being here yeah my pleasure thank you so
much for having me that's Colin Moriarty
you can check out Colin's last stand on
YouTube and Colin's on patreon we're
gonna do a patreon exclusive rapid-fire
thank you guys for watching and
hopefully the YouTube gods will allow
this stream to remain